we threw the spiritual baby out with the
religious bath water we are missing
something by throwing out religion
categorically we're missing some things
that religion gives us which is purpose
meaning and a sense of the Transcendent
the sense that there is something more
to strive for
the argument that our post-modern
culture has largely dismissed any notion
that Faith or spirituality can be a
collective Pursuit and and certainly not
the Bedrock of our society personal
beliefs should be just that personal
unique to every in each individual and
securely separated from the state my
guest today has a bit of a different
perspective Rayne Wilson rain Wilson
this is really what our show is all
about can you get a shot of this
[Music]
commitment He suggests a new way forward
through total spiritual Revolution what
he calls Soul boom now you might be
wondering why the guy best known for
portraying Dwight Schrute on the hit TV
series the office is here to wax lyrical
about matters spiritual but the truth is
that rain is a deep reservoir of wisdom
who has more than earned a position of
authority on matters ethereal first
Reign is the co-founder of the media
company Soul pancake which focused on
content related to The Human Experience
and positive social change he co-hosted
the podcast metaphysical milkshake with
Reza Aslan they came on the podcast
together a while back and that podcast
made a point of diving into the deep end
of topics religious and ethereal and
rain is also the author of the new book
Soul boom why we need a spiritual
revolution in this conversation we
discuss Reigns Baha'i faith is
conception of the Divine the importance
of finding meaning in life finding the
sacred in our everyday lives and why the
solutions to the existential problems we
currently face require a spiritual
Revolution
before we dive in this episode is
brought to you by Roca now I get asked
fairly consistently about the glasses
that you see me wearing on the show well
the answer is Roca these are
specifically the Hamilton frames I love
them all the frames that Roka makes are
high performance super light amazing
Optics they've got tons of great Styles
they never ever slip off my face and
I'll be sharing a bit more about Roka
later but for now enough let's uh let's
do the thing this is me and Rayne Wilson
great to see you man good seeing you
thank you for doing this thank you for
having me thank you for bringing the
Pacific Northwest weather to this
experience it's absolutely insane it's
crazy I got caught in a hail storm this
morning it literally looks like a
different place where we live right now
and I've I've lived here since
96. okay I don't know how long you've
lived here but I don't I don't remember
it I've never remember a colder wetter
crazier winter than this I was saying to
my wife because we're both from the
Pacific Northwest it feels like like the
Olympic Peninsula yeah Mia Bay
Washington it really does walls of like
dark green clouds and like rain every
other day pouring and uh it just it's
it's rainforest weather it's crazy it
really is and and for people that that
aren't familiar with Los Angeles I mean
we live in a desert and and there's lots
of out where we are there's lots of kind
of low-hanging mountain ranges that are
typically Brown and kind of just
scorched by the sun and the emergence of
green feels like this sort of weird
avatar-esque yeah kind of parallel
universe that we've suddenly found
ourselves in and it just reminds me of
of again you know kind of going to the
heart of some of the things you talk
about in the book like the regenerative
nature of the plan on it like left to
its own devices it finds a way and it's
repairing itself in real time and it's
amazing to see how green these Hills are
right now as much as I am over the rain
and kind of am pining for the sun right
now it is kind of a spectacular sight to
behold
it is it is I I hate to get I hate to
turn this conversation a little dark but
I was reading this article on climate
change and they were talk they were
putting this weather system in the
context of global climate change in
terms of Greater droughts and greater
flooding sure so it's just more extreme
condition of something awry yeah yeah
yeah because we had a nine-year drought
with hardly any rain at all and then uh
and now just like a Biblical Deluge I
know so uh we're not going to get too
dour too quickly you know because you
you strike an optimistic tone uh you
know I love the book the book is great I
read the whole book I love it thank you
um I can't wait to talk to you about it
and uh
um there is a there is a you know a
certainly a core of of Hope and and
optimism that kind of provides the
underpinning for all of these thoughts
says you kind of canvas spirituality and
religion and our place in the world and
how to you know uh think about and
approach solving some of the giant
problems that we face right now
yeah what I wanted to do
um and it was a it was a big swing uh
yeah uh it was kind of bold I'm not sure
if I succeeded but I wanted to
re-explore and reinvigorate uh spiritual
ideas
uh and
I wanted someone I wanted a reader
whether they're a born-again Christian
whether they're agnostic whether they're
spiritual but not religious whether
they're atheist to just kind of look at
the panopoly of spiritual ideas in uh in
an exciting new way through kind of some
new lenses although I hadn't thought of
that before oh that is interesting or or
there is there is a way to take a pers a
spiritual perspective on partisan
politics you know that spirituality is
not so many people view spirituality
it's such a weird word I even I hate it
coming out of my mouth sometimes I say
spirituality is like oh it's because to
so many people it uh connotates is that
a word
um connotes connotes
um to so many people the word
spirituality connotes uh
a religion an existing religion to a lot
of people it it means something very
vague a vague feeling in the heart
that's kind of an Airy fairy
hibbledy bibly hippie-ish kind of
yoga class and incense kind of vague
feeling and I not to dis on yoga or
meditation or even some great new age
Concepts or self-help books and works
and Concepts I love so many of them but
and to some people spirituality just
means like ghosts and angels and Spirits
you know and so but I wanted to
reinvigorate the word and you know the
subtitle of the book is why we need a
spiritual Revolution and to do so in
such a way that kind of maybe gives
people a kick in the ass about
spirituality and saying and and there's
a there's an urgency behind it this
isn't like a vague nice feeling kind of
word but there there is an urgency to
transform how we do pretty much
everything and the way that we can
transform is through the use of
spiritual tools
yeah and I think you did an incredible
and and beautiful job of doing that but
I kind of want to put a pin in that for
the moment because I think it's
important you were on the show I can't
remember how long ago it was a year and
a half ago or something like that yeah
two two was it two or three yeah I think
it was a while yeah um
and because that was sort of a unique
show where you and and Reza showed up
and and instead of kind of telling each
of your stories we just did these no
card things and tackled big problems
which we're gonna do again today I would
like to indulge you a little bit uh you
know spin the wheel and do a little bit
of uh what it was like what happened and
and what it's like now to help kind of
contextualize why these issues are
important to you sure
um
because as you kind of call out right at
the beginning of the book like what the
hell is this actor doing like writing
this big book about Big Ideas right like
how dare you you know Rayne Wilson who
you think you are right but these ideas
Run Deep throughout uh you know the
experience of your life dating all the
way back to Childhood and how you were
reared and the various experiences that
you've had over many years
indeed
um so I grew up a member of the Baha'i
faith
and I won't kind of go into detail about
that but for those who don't know the
Baha'i faith acknowledges the inherent
Divinity of all of the world's religions
that they all essentially come from the
same source and are gradually unfolding
chapters of one
Eternal faith of God of the Divine
and so growing up Baha'i we would meet
with Buddhists and I would meet Sikhs
and Born Again Christians and Mormons
and Muslims and we read holy books and
writings from all the world's Faith
faiths as well as Baha'i holy texts so
it was a very
uh idea of provoking
milieu to grow up in it's a it's a
somewhat obscure religion but there are
like I don't know five million people
that that practice this Faith that's
right are you perhaps the most famous
Baha'i are you the are you the are you
are you the Baha'i what Tom Cruise is oh
no don't say that oh my God I had to oh
man
um it's yeah it's a little it's a little
weird um so yeah there's about five or
six million Baha'is around the world
there's Pockets oh it's the second most
widespread of the world's religions next
to Christianity so no matter where you
go in the world there's buys it's right
it's pretty crazy it's kind of cool like
you can go to the Galapagos and there's
going to be some Baha'is you can go to
Mongolia there's some bahais or Malawi
and there's Baha'i communities it's very
but the numbers are not are not huge
yeah I'm I'm I'm one of the most
well-known because there's some other
actors and directors Justin baldoni
um he's a Baha'i and right Andy Grammer
the singer is a Baha'i Penn Badgley from
the show you and Netflix is by there are
some other Dizzy Gillespie was a Baha'i
when I grew up there was this band Seals
and Crofts sure Summer Breeze makes me
feel fine kind of a hippie band and they
were Baha'is and we were so happy
because they had this kind of like
beautiful spiritual kind of essence
through their music but
um yeah it's so it's a faith that I and
I talk about this a little bit in my
other book The bassoon King I talk about
how I left my faith for a long time and
went through those years kind of
wandering the desert and then I've come
back over the last you know 10 20 years
or so sure
um as as every good kind of spiritual
Seeker is want to do right uh we have to
we have to we have to venture a way to
come back and we have to figure these
things out for ourselves yeah endure our
own kind of challenges and and crises
and and you certainly allude to that you
know in the book and I'm interested in
in you don't have to be specific about
it but you know as you kind of emerged
out of the Cocoon of how you were
brought up and went to New York City and
started getting into you know theater
and acting what it was that drove you
back to the need or the desire or the
drive to search for something more
meaningful and and grounding like a you
know a guiding principle in your life
that that you know kind of when did you
back to your faith
the author Julia Cameron who wrote the
artist's sway
she wrote I came to spirituality
uh out of necessity not out of virtue
and that's how I would describe my path
so
when I left the Baha'i faith I was in my
20s I was in New York City and I wanted
nothing more than to be an actor I just
wanted to be a Bohemian downtown actor I
was going to NYU living in the East
Village
and
I really cast aside morality I didn't
want morality over my head I wanted to
have sex with my girlfriend and not feel
guilty about it I wanted to drink I
wanted to try drugs
um
I really kind of
let me put it this way I I drank the
Kool-Aid of contemporary society and
thinking that religion was of necessity
something that was for grandmothers and
for fearful people that needed like a
big daddy God to protect them so I
jettisoned anything and everything
having to do with religion at that time
[Music]
um
that was great for a few years it was it
was really awesome and I had an amazing
time I was working as an actor I was
living my dream for a nerdy Suburban boy
from Seattle and I'd never known a
single professional artist in my entire
life anyone who had ever gotten a paid a
dime to make art here I was like acting
in plays and yeah I was only getting
like 375 dollars a week but I was like I
was in plays and I was in New York City
and I was working with some great
theater directors and uh had a great
group of friends and I and I dove into
the study of of acting and and making of
Art and it was fantastic and you know to
to fast forward about like why was why
did spirituality become a necessity for
me like what I was dealing with at the
time we didn't have a name for in the
90s which was Mental Health crisis so I
started to have anxiety attacks
um that would leave me
crippled on the floor in a pool of sweat
I would have them sometimes on the
subway especially at the subway like was
paused or stuck I lived it way out in
Brooklyn like before Brooklyn was the
Brooklyn yes we know now I was out past
Williamsburg near Brownsville in an
abandoned beer brewery because I lived
there I was squatting there essentially
and when the subway would stop like
under Where the River was
and I would picture the river above the
head of over my head in the subway I
would start to have a meltdown on the
subway and I would start sweating and I
would just hoping people aren't noticing
like this sweat pouring off my face I
would start shaking I would have to hold
myself and and I I and
I got really really depressed for long
periods of time
um and I was using more and more alcohol
and drugs and this combination of
anxiety depression and then what I
realized now was addiction and I cycled
through I had my pot phase I had my Coke
phase I had you know and and alcohol all
through kind of an alcohol saturated
decade
I was lucky in the sense that
um because I'm in recovery now but I was
lucky in the sense that
I I wasn't a blackout drunk I I didn't I
wasn't I wasn't waking up in a pool of
my own vomit somewhere or something like
that but I I recognize that I used it on
a daily basis to medicate my own anxiety
and I was deeply deeply unhappy so and
this is what I was in this conundrum
Rich where
I was living my dream I literally if
like if you could go to 16 year old
Rayne Wilson like what's your dream live
in New York City be paid to be an actor
have cool friends have a beautiful
girlfriend live in a loft and uh have a
van and like collaborate artistically
with really cool people I mean I was
living my dream and I was miserable and
so that's when and that was before I
went into any 12-step programs I was
just like what the [__] is going on like
why
why am I waking up at three in the
morning just like staring at the wall
why am I considering suicide like what
how this doesn't make any [__] sense
it doesn't make any sense like I'm
living my dream this is what you wanted
[__] why are you so ungrateful
so
that started a long slow process of me
reinvestigating
faith God and religion because
in that again out of that necessity it
was kind of like
kill yourself
or investigate spirituality or
reinvestigate spirituality but I didn't
want to do it the way my parents would
have me do it I needed to do it in my
own way so I
cleared the decks and I just started
ground one like is there a god do I
believe in God I'm in my late 20s
living in Brooklyn with my girlfriend
depressed and anxious medicating myself
drinking every day
you know let me let me go on this
journey sure and as a good gen xer I
think we're about the same age right I'm
uh 42 yeah
you know the the sort of uh ethos or or
or kind of sensibility of our generation
is is a proclivity towards cynicism
irony everything sucks not really
nihilism but just sort of uh
you know a general kind of disinterest
in a lot of the things that the culture
or the generation that preceded us
prioritized and certainly religion and
spirituality despite your upbringing
were not only uncool but you know just
not you know part of the fabric of like
our age group right so it's not like to
me as somebody who's your you know you
know age peer like of course like you
move away from home and you distance
yourself from all of that I moved to New
York City too like I totally get it
um
but the interesting thing of you not
only deciding to you know embark on this
spiritual
Odyssey but then to find yourself
returning to the very faith that you
know was was part of your upbringing to
begin with is is super interesting
yeah it's kind of like The Godfather
like
what's that famous line they I wanted to
get out and they pulled me right back in
yeah uh that type of thing The Godfather
meets some sort of postmodern Gen X
Siddhartha Exploration with a little
Joseph Campbell mixed in
that's perfectly said and by the way I
love the way you summed up Gen X because
I had never heard someone sum it up in
that way but
there was this also this weird thing
about our generation isn't it
interesting about this whole idea about
selling out that people just don't have
these days oh not no worse like if you
were celebrated for like good for you
for creating your tequila brand or
whatever it is yeah if you were to go
you're the famous Rich roll ultra
marathoner nutrition vegan Wellness
Health spirituality expert and if you
were to go on a do a commercial for like
cereal bars from you know uh you know
Procter and Gamble or something like
that like these new like people would be
like yeah you go cash it in I know it's
so strange and but we really were like
oh if a band sold more than like 100 000
albums they were they sold out Nirvana
sold out leech was their best record
right right how dare they yeah let's
let's talk about Sonic Youth and you
know kind of live in the DIY sensibility
and anybody who breaks out uh you know
God forbid so there were great things
about that but like you said there's
also bad things where um you know it
gets too precious but at the same time
nowadays it's true like you can you know
just rampant Camp capitalism and and
selling out is is lauded anyway putting
that aside
so yeah this Joseph campbell-esque
journey of mine was very interesting I
think in the back of my head I always
knew I would probably come back to the
Baha'i faith because of all of the
world's faiths it's the most
I find the most kind of inclusive of a
wide range of ideas like the idea of me
becoming a a Buddhist or a Christian or
a Muslim or a Sikh or something like
that would it would have been a much
smaller slice of the pie whereas the
Baha'i faith because it's inclusive of
all of those World Views
um
it you know it's it feels more
arrived in a way but I had to start with
that essential question do I believe in
a God and and that took me years like
and I and I really
um
uh dug deep into that and I would talk
to my friends and it was very
interesting because they would all say
um
I would say Do you believe in God and
talk to my artsy Gen X friends and at
that time very few of them were straight
up atheists very few kind of said no I
don't I think there's just the universe
and we're just atoms and it's all random
and that's it very few people said that
most people were like I believe in some
kind of energy force out there
but I wouldn't call it God so they were
struggling with this idea of like a
daddy Santa Claus bearded white man God
on a cloud looking down on us
judgmentally
uh certainly as we all should struggle
with that idea of a God and discard it
immediately
um
and then I started reading I talk about
this in the book a little bit I started
reading uh Native American spirituality
a lot of books about it and that's when
the light bulb went on because the the
indigenous North American view of the
Creator is so rich and beautiful and
deep and inclusive and just profoundly
poetic and moving that it's
it's hard to dispute so in the in the
Lakota tradition
means the great mystery and
and I remember at like 27 or 28 having a
conversation with my friend I was like I
don't know if I can believe in God but I
can believe in the great mystery
we're brought to you today by Roca
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuilt
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code Rich Roll at roca.com or
you can click the link in the
description below okay back to the show
[Music]
this idea that that God is not a bearded
man but is more like a pervasive energy
that that it's not
it's not like a who it's like this thing
that surrounds us and that that that Sue
idea that you explore in the book is
super interesting it's like uh what did
you say I wrote it down in the notes but
um
it's not a um it's not a what but it's
uh what did I do what I wrote it down I
can't find it it's a house yeah it's a
how right it's less God is less of ah
yeah it's God is a how not a what and
you explain this idea like the analogy
you use is think of God as like the
internet where where Wi-Fi is the Holy
Spirit and computers are our souls so
it's this like diffused energy that
exists everywhere from which we are not
separate which is a distinct departure
from the notion of the the monotheistic
you know God that's like sort of peering
down upon us as a separate thing
the Theologian David Bentley heart
um
talks about most people's conception of
God and when when atheists talk about
not believing in a god what they're
describing is a demiurge and this word
demiurge is really interesting it's like
it's like a Marvel character it's like
this all-powerful being among other
beings that has the power to create
words I mean excuse me that has the
power to create worlds that is looking
down on us that can cast Thunder and can
cause Miracles and can look into your
mind and read your thoughts like Dr
Xavier you know from the X-Men and
um so getting away from anything
demiurgical toward I also describe God
uh in a parallel to some larger forces
like beauty or the concept of love
and you might say well I don't know if I
can believe in God but I certainly
believe in love
and
you know we can be shown that love on a
brain scan lights up certain areas of
our brain and and it's there from a
behavioralist point of view to help us
create families and and propagate the
species that's the only reason it exists
and you could kind of say well nonsense
I know in my heart that love is more
than just a couple of neurons firing in
my brain and the propagation of the
species I I have experienced it on with
so many different facets and and
varieties and variables and nuances and
I've experienced it holistically and
I've and for my wife and when I held my
child in the hospital in the in the
hallway and Van Nuys at three in the
morning and I I experience it when I'm
in nature and so that experience of that
force of Love is much more akin to what
I hope people will think of when they
think about God or the Divine less uh as
some kind of being among other beings
that has superpowers sure and as the one
sort of biological creature that has the
capacity to really
um you know Embrace these you know these
types of emotions uh that we can't
actually locate within the brain the
cranium right where does love exist how
do we Define it like what is it exactly
where does awe and wonder sit and how do
we think about that and why do these
impulses and these emotions
um live within us and and and why are
they provoked by you know certain chords
of music or somebody on a stage you know
you know sort of in the midst of their
pathos or or or whatnot and what do we
make of that and how do we extrapolate
from those very human experiences to
think more broadly about what is
actually going on like how do we
telescope up from that and consider more
deeply our place here on planet Earth
and in the universe and
um and and and and and [__] a dude
like what is it all about right like
that's what this book is like you know
what's up for you rain you know not much
just Consciousness and God and
spirituality and religion and and and
you know the need for a spiritual
Revolution to solve our existential
problems you know are we on the cusp of
something new are we at a break point
that is going to lead to the decimation
of of
ecosystems and perhaps Humanity itself
like what are we actually talking about
here how are we going to solve these
problems and you know this book is
really a call to action in that the
solutions that we seek cannot be found
found within the parameters and the
structures of the limited systems that
continually push us in the wrong
direction but instead require
a whole cloth uh you know new way of
looking at all of these problems and the
capacity of human beings and erecting
new Solutions like it's almost you know
it is a revolutionary act this book
you're asking a lot of the audience and
reading it but it's also very you know
hopeful in that regard would you like to
do my book tour for me
that's what we're doing right now that
was better so help me help you right
that was better said and more articulate
than anything I've ever said about the
book previous yeah so I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna copy that I'm gonna
write that down and repeat it
um very well said
um
so
the book kind of has
various parts to it and I I'm I'm not
sure what the question should I go right
to the spiritual Revolution I want to
just talk about whatever's coming up for
you okay it wasn't a question no no
here's what was fun to me
about this book I have a chapter on
death death is one of my favorite topics
um in fact I felt so
uh proud where I got my first call from
someone who said hey my sister is dying
of cancer
can you talk to her about death
and I felt
so that was one of the greatest phone
calls I've ever received in my life like
I feel honored and inspired I love the
topic we're all gonna do it
you and I rich might be 20 years might
be 40 years
we're all riding around in Meet suits we
got about 90 some years uh if we're
lucky and our Essence what I will call
our soul continues on an infinite
journey to uh
to create to meet the Divine Source
whatever that looks like infinite
infinite worlds of of the Divine of the
holy of the Sacred that await us on our
journey past this physical plane
so I got to write about death I lost my
dad he didn't die of covid but during
covet of of heart disease about two
years ago and it was one of the most
profound and uh disturbing and
heart-rending experiences of my life and
I write about that in the book I got to
write a chapter on God because God is as
you can tell is one of my favorite
topics as well I get into Consciousness
I have discussions of aliens looking
down on planet Earth and talking about
you know what these ridiculous human
beings are going through
uh uh down on the planet I got to just
pose super fun
uh conversations I talk about my
favorite TV shows from the 70s and
they're kind of through a spiritual lens
which is kung fu
trust me we're gonna get into it oh okay
good we'll get into that yeah but but
like you said in your in your uh in your
summary uh where it's all leading and
the point I really wanted to make is
like just plain and simple okay just
where rubber meets the road like totally
practical the way current systems are
set up they are based on the worst of
humanity you think about the worst of
humanity what do you think of
lust greed aggression
you think about one upsmanship and kind
of a rampant individuality uh that
overrides a community
um
these terrible qualities of humanity
competition uh
uh now there's healthy competition
there's even a certain amount of healthy
aggression but they have run rampant in
every existing system you take any
system education
Healthcare certainly politics
international relations
uh just capitalism uh in general they're
based on the worst qualities of humanity
and we need to like throw out completely
uh in and find practical ways to do this
this is not some like
John Lennon imagine all the people
living life in peace kind of hippy-dippy
stuff like there there has to we have to
find solutions that bring spiritual uh
spiritually based systems of interaction
[Music]
um
to bear on on how we run everything on
planet Earth and if we don't we're
headed off a cliff sure so right now we
tend to address the problems that we
have with Band-Aids whether it's
campaign Finance reform or
gerrymandering or Health Care reform
what have you these are all sort of
small short-term fixes that are blind to
the dysfunctional underpinnings of the
system itself right so short of a
complete revamp a social and spiritual
Revolution that allows us to kind of
deconstruct and dismantle the systems
themselves they will continue to
perpetuate and drive us you know towards
the edge of that Cliff because they're
they're premised upon these uh these
predilections of humanity which are you
know not great as you mentioned you know
read power lust this zero-sum game
mentality comp you know the worst of
competition that are pitting us against
ourselves and uh you know basically in
so doing uh alienating ourselves from
from the beauty of our innate humanity
and the unity that we share like our
inability to actually see and embrace
the fact that we are all one and that
what we share and who we are is much
more alike than what differentiates
ourselves and we're just quibbling over
[__] as we you know sort of
accelerate towards the precipice of this
Cliff this is what's happening
these problems are ranging from small to
extremely existential and yet I can't
help even in you know you know kind of
the the beauty of what you propose in
this book
um it's hard for me to be optimistic
about our capacity to get our [__]
together uh and and not only like see
and identify this but actually take the
actions required to deconstruct and then
reconstruct the systems that would set
us on a better path yeah
um you brought up a lot of things let me
get to a few of them
first let me start at the end with the
optimism
uh I get it
um it's very hard for me to remain
optimistic as well and I do think and I
use the analogy of like
a teenager having to go to rehab like
humanity is in its teenage years
Humanity right now in its development is
literally like 16 and a half
thrashing around kind of it's kind of
following its worst most base impulses
and you know using opioids and oil and
materialism and consumerism and the
narcissism of social media to kind of uh
hit bottom yeah [__] you and hit bottom
and needs to be carted away to rehab and
go hiking around the mountains of Utah
for a while but what is that bottom like
how far does that elevator have to go
down and we have that Reckoning and we
hope that it's not a nuclear war and we
hope it's not a breakdown of all
societal structures we hope that we're
able to kind of like hit a soft bottom
and not a hard bottom to use a 12-step
parlance but
you know look at Rwanda for instance uh
underwent one of the uh most gruesome uh
atrocities of uh
um of Carnage in human history and now
you know the way that they have uh the
tribes there the Tutsi and Hutu who have
have have healed
um the conflict and the the way they
have set the economy uh forward and the
way women are used in politics and kind
of uh there's been a profound sea change
and shift in how that country works so
you brought up a great point one of the
things that I stress again and again in
here is about politics one of the things
that is my personal pet peeves that I
hate more than anything is partisan
politics because partisanship is
immediately like how much money can I
raise how much can I denigrate the other
party how much can I try and assert uh
power and control over them at all costs
we have stopped seeking solutions to
really difficult problems
um and everything becomes polarized yeah
it's not solution oriented at all it's
about throwing grenades at the other
side it's about owning the libs or
pointing out you know the stupidity of
the other side
quibbling uh you know at the cost of
actually solving problems and that's
really a systemic ill of uh you know of
the greater structure right like part of
it is driven by you know kind of maybe
what's wrong with human beings like
we're we're sort of you know we we like
we get activated by that sort of
discourse and certainly social media
amplifies all of that and I think is
exacerbating this problem
um but we need systems and structures
that that incentivize and bring out the
best of us as opposed to the worst of us
and I feel like that's the pivot that
you're speaking to in the book well I
so in partisan politics um
you you talked earlier about Band-Aids
people are like well we need a
you know we need 20 Supreme Court
Justices that'll solve the problem we
need campaign Finance report reform
that'll solve the problem you know we
need less gerrymandering that'll solve
the problem it's we are looking for
these fixes but the entire system is
based on [__] you I'm gonna own you
least let me say this for an example
when there are debates
what's the headline the next day who got
in the best zingers against the other
person they were debating oh Kamala
Harris got this incredible Zinger in Joe
Biden did the Zinger oh Donald Trump
really took down Hillary Clinton there
like that's how what we're celebrating
we're celebrating the ability to stand
on a stage and cut someone else down but
that also speaks to the unhealthy
incentives of the media and social media
and the algorithms and the way dopamine
Works in our brain it all works together
so an example that I bring up in Soul
boom to get really again because I I
feel like spiritual solutions to these
problems need to be super practical and
if they're not it's again it's just this
kind of Airy fairy kind of vague idea
I use an example from the Baha'i faith
so in the Baha'i faith
uh it's a there's no clergy it's all
democratically elected so here we are in
this suburb outside of La in this
particular suburb I don't know if you
tell people where you record this
um secret uh the uh there is an assemb
every year the Baha'is elect an assembly
of that nine most spiritually mature
people to guide the community right
every year we and we do this silent
ballot prayerful we meditate write it
down put in slip and paper you don't
know who did it we've got tellers they
tally it there's no yard signs there's
no campaigning there's no fundraising
now you can say well that's fine in a
small religion of you know a couple
hundred thousand in the United States
but
how would that work well let's say this
small suburb out of here in La decided
one day hey we're sick and tired of
toxic partisan politics so this suburb
here we are in Thousand Oaks California
we want to do things differently we want
to have an election and we're going to
meet at this High School
cafeteria and everyone from the
community is going to show up and we're
there's going to be no campaigning no
yard signs no money no money is going to
change hands not about money it's not
about power and in the city of Thousand
Oaks we're going to think of the nine
most
maybe not spiritual but let's say wise
mature and selfless public servants we
can think of we're going to write them
down on a piece of paper and we're gonna
find the people that tally the most
votes and we're going to ask them to
serve one term of one year three years
five years whatever it is to selflessly
serve to meet the needs of that
Community now can you imagine doing that
on a small scale maybe you can imagine
that in a small town maybe a Tiny Town
in Iowa decides to do that let's say and
then it spreads and then you could say a
county could do that or a state could do
that could we eventually do that in a
way I I think we could it might sound
pie in the sky but wouldn't that be such
a better alternative to the to literally
the hundreds of millions of dollars that
are changing hands every year money that
could be used for social benefit and
instead is used for campaign ads that no
one under 60 listens to anyway and their
play on repeat on Fox no news and MSNBC
and during you know infomercials like
it's an insane amount of waste and money
and Corruption
perpetuating a broken system yeah I I
mean I I I love it and I also can't help
but think perhaps that is a little pie
in the sky because humans are our own
worst enemies and I imagine the guy
who's like yeah I know what rain's
saying but I know if if I elect this guy
he's gonna let me uh you know sidestep
regulations and build that fence in my
front yard that right now the city's not
letting me do and he told me secretly
that if I you know like workarounds sure
right like we are you know we'll always
devolve to you know self-interest and I
think perhaps that speaks to you know
something I want to explore with you
which is
you know perhaps uniquely American which
is this idea of rugged individualism
like it's really about me and what I
want to do and like my Liberty versus
the responsibility to the collective and
you kind of couch this in in a really
great
um analogy uh that that I love because
I'm your age which is Star Trek versus
kung fu right now as a child of the 70s
when I think back to my childhood I
think of
you know banana seats Schwinn bikes and
Virginia Slims and and brown
refrigerators and you know all the
greatness that the the 70s gave us uh
but perhaps the greatest gift of the 70s
you know at least for me as a nerd a
fellow nerd maybe not as much of a nerd
as you but uh I was a rabid Star Trek
fan and just less of a Kung Fu fan we'll
get to that but
Star Trek was my jam yeah I was the guy
who went to Star Trek conventions and
like the whole thing right of course
yeah um and and even now maybe it's that
thing when you're at a certain age like
stuff becomes indelible and you
irrationally fall in love with it and
still think that it's the greatest but
the original William Shatner Star Trek
uh was so beautiful and I loved how you
talked about it in the book because
what it did was it really grappled with
like big social issues and did it in a
really entertaining way right and and
that was it in the book you sort of say
well this is the collective spirituality
um that we need to sort of consider more
profoundly and then in turn Kung Fu
being an example of rugged individual
spirituality like the internal
development that we need in terms of a
spiritual Revolution and you pause it
this idea of merging these two
sensibilities individual uh spiritual
Evolution and a a you know a true kind
of
um
uh uh uh
prioritization of the importance of of
you know Collective responsibility and
and and and and responsibility to kind
of elevating the whole that is missing
from our current culture so maybe Riff
on that a little bit or explain you
summed it up perfectly I think the
spiritual journey
um in contemporary Society is very much
the Kung of the Kung Fu variety so in
kung fu for people who don't know uh
Kwai Chang Kane uh is a Chinese Shaolin
monk he's actually uh I think he's half
Caucasian in the show originally it's
cast a white white guy yeah we should
note the racism of the show which was
invented by Bruce Lee they stole the
idea and cast a white guy in the show
which was just horrific but nonetheless
the show was brilliant and David
Carradine who played Kwai Chang Kane who
studied Kung Fu and spirituality in the
in a Shaolin Monastery in China he goes
to the old west in the 1870s 1880s
looking for his brother so he's on this
quest to find his brother and he's
taking his wealth of Knowledge from his
background from The Shaolin Monastery
with the there's flashbacks to these
beautiful monks that are teaching him
the you know you know be Supple be
Supple is the willow tree and the wind
you know kind of Concepts and he's
taking that into a racist
aggressive uh violent old west and
every day he's on his path meeting up
with some racist cowboy and there's
always a couple of good fights and some
Kung Fu fights there but he's also most
of the show is kind of talking about
concepts of forgiveness and healing and
acceptance and compassion and some of
these you know profound and Universal
spiritual ideas
so
for most contemporary Americans at least
in secular cities that's what a
spiritual journey is considered that
what do I do what are the tools that I
use at a yoga class and my meditation in
my reading and listening to Eckhart
Tolle who I love
um you know these these spiritual guides
and teachers along the way we've got you
know Rumi on Instagram and you know we
and we try and make ourselves better
people we try and incorporate Divine
qualities in our lives we try and find
peace and surrender and serenity in our
daily lives and as we go out into the
milieu of modern life stuck in traffic
and horrible bosses and backstabbing
fellow employees and and and screwed up
teenage kids that are are lost and we're
trying to use
what we've learned in our on our journey
uh to make ourselves better and kind of
and and stay on the path so that's one
side of spirituality and it's a very
important one right and that's it's the
spirituality we nurture in the garden of
our hearts and we take with us on our
daily Journey but Star Trek
to your point I see as a metaphor for a
larger spiritual context which is that
Humanity when Star Trek Begins has had a
giant War
and they came together after this giant
World War III they don't really talk
about what that looked like but it was
mass decimation and Humanity has greatly
matured because of it and has healed
racism and has healed income inequality
and uh has brought the all the planet
together into kind of a a one world
government that is a just government
and they are then able to focus on
technology and healing there's no
poverty at home no one is starving
um and they're able to go explore outer
space you got strange in the world and
humans seem to be liberated from their
base in instincts somehow
we're not quite sure how that happened
but it seems to be the case well it's
kind of the Chicken and the Egg isn't it
I mean if you have a society that's
eliminated these kind of uh building
blocks of inequity and Injustice you
know I think it's much easier for our
higher Natures to flourish yeah and in
fact Roddenberry insisted in Star Trek
the new Next Generation and if you
notice this and you read about the show
in the Next Generation there's no
conflict at all right so the TV writers
very difficult to create drama how do
you create a TV show when no one
disagrees with each other but you never
hear like number one or Decker or Wharf
going up I disagree I don't think we
should go work before I think we need to
go warp too they're past no I don't know
that humans will ever go past
disagreement but there is what I view as
kind of a necessary Evolution a
transformation uh a maturity of humanity
that we are able to connect with the
other species of the universe and and
but I'm fascinated by about what life on
Earth is like during Star Trek when
they're out gallivanting around uh solar
systems sure and they happen upon
certain civilizations that serve as
metaphors for social issues that we were
that we were grappling with and continue
to Grapple with now in our times and you
highlight you know two of the you know
the sort of more notable episodes the
you know the the episode where half the
Fate the the aliens half the face is
black half is white and you know you
don't even realize as a viewer until
halfway into it these people that are
Con in conflict with each other yeah
they're on up the black and the wider on
opposite sides of their face and you
realize how Preposterous that is as a
sort of analogy or metaphor for race
relations yeah you know as as we
currently contend with them and let's
not forget the first interracial kiss in
television history yeah uh was uh Kirk
and Uhuru
um uh Michelle Nichols Yeah the gorgeous
Michelle Nicholson well I got to meet
before her oh you did wow yeah wow it
was it was Legend yeah um
so and that did more for for race
relations moving forward race relations
than almost any other event on
television in in many ways yeah and and
as you kind of aptly point out of the
book it's it's not that the kiss
happened it's how they kind of low-keyed
the whole thing like yeah yeah big deal
yeah right we're human beings we're or
of the human race right and so in the
book I'm going to read a little
section
um where you kind of uh
talk about like how these two like the
sort of kung fu sensibility and the Star
Trek Star Trek sensibility have to come
together to you know create the
foundation for this new spiritual
Revolution that you're talking about and
you say
what good is a spiritual path that only
enriches our own inner peace well
hundreds of millions go hungry in other
words like the Kung Fu thing of just
focusing on self right and conversely
how do we sustainably serve those
Millions if our hearts are hard empty
cold and filled with selfish ego or
materialistic motives How can there be
peace without Justice
there is an ongoing dance a conversation
between the two-fold moral paths that
lie ahead of us we seek personal
Enlightenment so that we can serve more
have an outward orientation and help
create a better world and when we
undertake this service we are in turn
internally awakened and fulfilled to an
even even greater degree damn I wrote
that profound [__] from like like this
Dwight Schrute character
dude jeez yeah like how are we supposed
to take you seriously
um I don't have an answer for that
um that's good [__] though man thanks
yeah thanks yeah
uh I appreciate that and
um and I'm glad that that stuck out
because I I view it as like a yin and
yang shape that these two
I try rain Wilson I try to be a better
person every day I try and be more
patient with my wife and my kid and I
look at my Character defects you know
like we're doing 12-step programs I can
be really judgmental I can be impatient
you know I have I have to work on these
and get better and then I also feel like
something that many Americans have lost
track of is this idea that
um you know bawala the founder of the
Baha'i faith says all men were created
to Usher forth in ever advancing
civilization
so
part of our spiritual purpose
is to help
all of us
move forward whatever that means that
doesn't mean you need to be Mother
Teresa it can mean that at your job as
an accountant you have great integrity
and you refuse to backbite about the
other accountants there's all kinds of
ways
that we can be of service and be moving
the ball down the field toward human
transformation and maturity and I found
this in the office you know like
I can't tell you like every day online
or in person I hear from people like
thank you so much for the show we
recently
it's recently been 10 years since we did
our very final episode and I posted
about it on Instagram and the thousands
of comments like thank you for your show
it it it it soothed us it made our
family laugh my my mother was really
sick and we would watch it together my
parents were going through a divorce and
my siblings and I would watch it
together it helped me through a mental
health crisis it helped me through covid
like who would have thunk that something
as silly as like a bunch of you know
weird denizens in a paper company you
know doing a sitcom could have provided
that kind of a service to a lot of
people and certainly not why any of us
did I got the job because I wanted a
house yeah you know I just the fact that
like perhaps even more people watched it
in recent years than even when it came
out like the long tail on this thing and
you know the kind of audience building
that's happened even over the past of
the the past couple years is
unbelievable with this thing I mean it
really is a unicorn in that sense
um I'm profoundly lucky I have so many
friends that are actors and so many of
them have been on shows that
we haven't even
heard I had a friend who was on the show
Yes dear which was right before the
office had twice our numbers three times
our numbers yeah no one talks about
Yes dear oh I can't wait to get home and
watch some episodes of yester I'm not
[__] on the show you know it's fine
funny you know sitcom but the fact that
the office has uh has legs and has great
it has a kind of a timelessness oddly
enough
um
offices look like offices there's
fluorescent lights and there's phones
and there's desks and there's crazy
bosses and there's and you're all
archetypes that everybody can identify
like they all know their version of you
know the character that you play there's
a Pam in a gym in every office sure and
there's a Dwight in every office and
there's some version of Michael Scott
and and that's the other funny thing
about the office is
the fans
are young they've never set foot in an
office most of the fans that watch the
show are teenagers and college kids uh
and the people who discover the show and
watch it they've never even
they don't know what a fax machine is or
a copy machine or a you know a staff
meeting or anything like that that was
the thing that was greatly surprising to
us like all of a sudden when we were
almost canceled a dozen times and then
all of a sudden we started getting the
numbers in like we the average age of
your viewer is 24. it's like whoa that's
crazy because we thought it would be
people in their 30s and 40s that worked
in offices after all yeah I mean my kids
are great examples of that I mean it's
so interesting like what do you make of
that I think you you you you tapped into
it I think it's a um
uh I think it's the universals of the
characters and it it is a I think the
office is a vision of what are working
in an office might be and
very often I find people that write
online and they say
I want to work in an office like in the
office and like they want to work in
like a menial nine to five and I'm like
no don't do it you're missing the whole
thing how soul-crushing it can be it's
not always you know but uh
but you know going connecting that to
the book one of the interesting things
with um Millennials and gen Z is that
for years when they would ask young
people what's the most important thing
you're looking for in a job uh they
would say
you know uh pet good pay high status
like people will think highly of me by
having being sales manager or senior
executive or what have you
um you know commute from home being in
the community I want you know perks like
healthcare Etc there was always this
list and it was the same for decades
then all of a sudden we found when I was
working at Seoul pancake this digital
media company I had that we found and it
was around 2010 2012
all of a sudden like making a difference
in the world
was shot to the top like number one two
or three uh for Millennials and gen Z
all of a sudden there was a questioning
of why are we doing this again I don't
necessarily want money status an easy
commute uh and perks out of my job like
I wanna be a part of something that that
makes a difference and uh I think that's
also this is a really lost couple of
generations and I I don't mean that in a
derogatory way but I think lost in
questioning
um uh I think mental the Mental Health
crisis obviously is just through the
roof and it's devastating it's something
to talk about in the book a great deal
um but you do I they're going back to
Hope
I think these younger Generations really
have their eye on something greater in a
way that we didn't as Jenna sure my son
is 18 years old
and
my wife said that she found him in tears
because he found out that Biden had
okayed this Willow petroleum oil
exploration in Alaska and opening up a
national park in Alaska for a new
Drilling even though that went goes
against everything he campaigned for and
every promise the Democratic party made
about a green New Deal and whatnot and
what do you hear silence silence he's
opening up Alaska for drilling but if a
republican had opened up Alaska for
drilling the Democrats would be like
again the toxicity of partisanship and
the hypocrisy of partisanship my son was
in tears over this and
and he also came up to me the other day
and he said dada when no one's around he
calls me data if someone else is around
he calls me father
he's like dada I was like I was like
what's going on Walter what's in your
heart right now and he's like Dada I'm
really upset about income inequality I'm
really I was re I was researching it
watching these YouTube videos like the
middle class is shrinking and the haves
are getting heavier and the have-nots
are getting half naughtier and it's
really really [__] up I'm very very
upset about it and we had a long talk
about
you know socialism and social programs
and how the middle class was initially
created in the United States and so this
younger generation they're very tuned in
to what the world needs yeah that that
is a source of great optimism for me
because certainly that was not my
sensibility when I was 1921. you know
like and the fact that there is this new
generation of people who you know very
much are prioritizing meaning purpose
impact into the bigger decisions they're
making about how to invest their time
and what career to to pursue
is extraordinary yeah we like to [__] on
young people and oh whatever but
um you know that's really beautiful and
laudable and I'm not sure
from
Wentz that you know emanates like what
is the what is the source of that is it
is it really just uh you know a greater
objective perspective on what's actually
happening where they're looking at it
and thinking
this is not right we can correct this
every generation obviously to your point
earlier is here to kind of elevate
Consciousness and and push us forward
progress humanity and hopefully a better
Direction but when you think back on why
this younger generation is seeing things
in that way like how do you make sense
of that okay let's look at the hippie
days
if you went into a coma in 1964
with a nice trim haircut such as you're
demonstrating
and you did have long hair but I'm sure
you but yeah
um and uh and you woke up from that coma
in 1974.
and they're like hello Rich wake up oh
thank God oh you're saved you've been in
a coma for 10 years you'd be like oh
okay great great so what's going on
it's like
10 years okay what's going on well we
have the Beatles and we had Led Zeppelin
and we had the race riots and we had the
Vietnam War and we had the protests and
we had the bra burnings and we had
Watergate and you know like
it would be jaw dropping the amount of
change be like wait a minute guys aren't
just wearing skinny black ties and
skinny black suits and going to their
their jobs in their in their Oldsmobiles
like what the hell is going on where's
where's the Eisenhower America that I
knew you know back then you know uh we
have you know finally you know rights
for for for black Americans and
legislation uh kind of putting a nail in
the coffin of Jim Crow like it's a
completely different world so I think
and I hope one of these days we're at a
turning point now there were a lot of
problems in the hippie days we all know
how kind of drugs and sex got involved
and that kind of
everything just moved towards drugs and
sex land and by the mid 70s everyone was
just getting baked and and loving the
one they're with and we kind of lost
sight of like real social change but
maybe we're at an inflection a similar
kind of inflection point
I think there's uh I think there's a lot
of Truth to that and and in thinking
about that
we have the young people with this
elevated sensibility of responsibility
and purpose which I think is really
beautiful that's that's a Star Trek
sensibility right we we come from more
of the Kung Fu sensibility me me me yep
and uh you know in my own kind of
personal relationship with religion and
spirituality I probably fall into the
camp of of you know this idea that you
explore in the book which is
you know our own personal bespoke uh
relationship with spirituality right
like like this idea that that uh you
know we're in this era where
religion is on the decline you know
people of Our Generation had the
experiences that we had growing up with
various
doctrines and churches that were kind of
resistant to and we're finding our own
um connection to meaning through these
this sort of Pastiche of various
spiritual principles whether that's
through yoga or Hinduism we're kind of
patching these things together to try to
find meaning in our own lives and I
probably put myself in that category on
some level
um
and then matching that and and that's a
very individualistic thing like it's
about me and my relationship with myself
in the world and how can I be a better
person
um
on top of that
with the decline in religious Traditions
at least within the context of the
United States we're seeing the rise of
the secular Guru right like you talk
about celebrity and sports stars and the
people that have sort of supplanted
um religious figures or leaders as
people that we look to for guidance or
for inspiration but one thing that you
kind of left out in that discussion
are these new figures that are on the
social media landscape that a lot of
people are gravitating towards for
inspiration for wisdom for guidance For
Better or For Worse right the Jordan
Peterson's or the who you know pick your
pick whoever Russell Brand people like
that
um who in many ways
to my mind seemed to have stepped into
the place of the local pastor at the
church or you know the the kind of uh
Community figure that would have
galvanized uh you know the young people
within that community so how are you
like how do you look at that and think
about that
I think that's very well said and you're
right I I I'm kind of like kicking
myself oh yeah I should have talked more
about that because it's true and you
look at the veneration that Elon Musk
gets for instance and a lot of the
Silicon Valley startup kind of guy the
billionaires and the the tech the
technologists and you know these are
demigods right sure and then on the
internet you have
um
the what's that [__] who got arrested
in Romania Andrew Tate yeah you have the
Andrew Tates who are just despicable
materialistic sexist violent uh idiots
and then you have people that have
enormous followings of people
you know particularly young men in the
you know in the age bracket of of your
son Walter right right I'm sure he has
friends who are sort of cottoned on to
this guy's messaging and what that's
doing like there's very real
implications for all of this yeah it's
it's very real and but you also have
people like Jay Shetty sure and uh you
know there's in the podcast world
there's Louis house and
um uh four hour work week what's that
guy uh Tim Ferriss like yeah like the
podcast of sphere yeah and they have a
lot of great wisdom to offer and I would
and I'm gonna challenge you on this
because
you say that you have a bespoke
spirituality and I kind of make fun of
it in the book a little bit like oh I
like this yoga class and I like this
roomy quote but the Baha'i faith is sort
of that too
first I'm going to disabuse you of your
own thought because what what did you do
you created a podcast I I'm sure that
you just like having deep conversations
and it's fun for you but you have helped
millions of people toward greater health
and wellness and well-being in in your
work so you are a hundred percent part
of the solution in what you're doing you
could have just stayed been an ultra
marathon or gotten a job at a running
shoe company you know made a nice living
or what have you and gotten sponsorships
and just kind of like enjoyed your yoga
class and your meditation app right but
you took it a step further how is the
Baha'i faith different because I'm not
here to promote the Baha'i faith but one
of the things I talk about in the book
is like we threw the spiritual baby out
with the religious bathwater
so
in in our kind of especially secular
left Urban
um contemporary America we have rejected
anything and everything having to do
with religion for a very good reason for
a very very good reason let me underline
that for very good reasons religions
have brought some of the worst pain and
suffering and grotesque aspects of human
nature to Bear over the last couple
thousands of years that you could ever
possibly imagine and every decade you
read about some new horror that you know
the Catholic church or that evangelicals
have engendered but I do think that
there we are missing something by
throwing out religion categorically
we're missing some things that religion
gives us which is purpose meaning
community and a sense of the
Transcendent the sense that there is
something more to strive for there's a
lot more to the very best of religion
and I try and I have a chapter on kind
of the universals of religious faiths
why Buddhism and Islam and and
Christianity are why and how they're
connected the essential ideas that bind
them together and even have a chapter
called hey kids let's invent a new
religion where I'm like let's let's take
the very best that religion has brought
Humanity over the last three or four
thousand years let's take the best ideas
from that put it together in a jambalaya
and make our new religion because we
which you call Soul boom I call it Soul
boom trademark
um but I also refuse categorically to be
any kind of Guru or leader of the Soul
boom religion but I I posit it kind of
jokingly but at the same time there are
some by throwing out religion and we see
this current Mental Health crisis and if
you
have you have you read the work of Dr
Lisa Miller uh the awakened brain yeah I
had her on the podcast oh great okay
she's amazing sorry I missed that one
yeah I love that come on
she's great but there's hard data that
supports how spirituality and religion
itself
makes people happier greater well-being
Greater Community uh more resilient uh
which you know resilience is one of the
big factors in the Mental Health crisis
so it's something to be explored you
know and I can already hear all the
people right now switching off the
podcast and like throwing things across
the room [__] that I'll never be a part
of religion that's so evil and it's like
I get it I get it it has been it's true
but there are some Universal beautiful
truths in religious practice and let me
say this
spirituality there has to be some kind
of systemic sensibility to spirituality
if we want to achieve social
transformation if we want that Star Trek
World there has to be some kind of
systematic practice that leads in that
direction so that's how I would say
different that the Baha'i faith offers
some again I'm not trying to like
convert people but the the what I love
about the Baha'i faith is that there are
it it Fosters Grassroots Community
spiritual movements in a systematic way
right and I think sorry go ahead people
Gathering to pray together bringing
diverse people together being of service
together uh Children and Youth classes
that are for that are focused on
spiritual virtues Divine virtues you
know the the very best kind of character
and Leadership qualities that Humanity
has to offer these are ways of building
a Grassroots Community movement that but
you don't have to be a Baha'i to partake
in this but some kind of systematization
other than a like you say bespoke
spirituality I think is crucial sure in
order to really shift the tectonic
plates of of culture and society and and
you know progress Humanity or Elevate
Consciousness you not only need the
revolutionaries and the chaos agents you
need a foundation yes and a structure
and an organizing principle right and
over the history of Grassroots movements
and uprisings Etc the opposition is
always much more organized yes than the
revolutionaries yeah I did so you see
this played out time and time again and
you happily you know very astutely you
know kind of highlight that in the book
which is this idea that if we do want to
uh manifest the change that I think we
can all agree that that we need we need
to be organized on the level of you know
the opposition right so how do we do
that and not fall prey to the pitfalls
of you know Humanities basist nature and
so what do we do we look to
organizations that have figured this out
or thrived you mentioned the Baha'i
faith that's figured out some version of
this and you also point out 12-step like
Alcoholics Anonymous this decentralized
a lot to talk about like
decentralization with cryptocurrency and
all of that well look at AAA this is
this is this amazing revolutionary
movement that has thrived and grown
decade after decade after decade why how
why did it not
um you know implode uh you know due to
the you know peccadillos
in charge
only way to do this and I've I've banged
this drum so many times but it's almost
like they should teach this model at
Harvard Business School or you know
figure out like you know management
Consultants should you know really do a
forensic Deep dive into you know how
this came to be because there's there's
true wisdom to be gleaned absolutely
this magical mystical thing that kind of
you know percolated up through uh you
know a combination of of need and uh
and and uh I I don't know what else but
the fact that this thing exists and is
functional today have you ever been to
is have you ever seen or been to an AAA
meeting in a super remote location I
remember once traveling through uh
mountains of Guatemala and I saw the
little AAA logo logo over just some tin
Hut and I didn't go in but I walked by
and I just had a little
you know curtain blowing in the breeze
and they were you know there was 20 you
know Mayan
you know laboring Farmers
uh that kind of had that ancient kind of
Mayan mountain look to them in a circle
sharing praying you know they had
obviously all hit bottom with drinking
in some way and I was I was moved
profoundly to tears like how incredible
that Bob and Bill would have these
discussions and then this thing would
spread to this little Hut in the
mountains of Guatemala where these
people are getting
solace consultation companionship
guidance surrender and and wisdom and it
it is and that is the it is the
archetypal Grassroots movement that has
spread around the world and helped
millions and we could learn a hell of a
lot from it right how do we extract the
best of that and apply that template on
onto you know a new model of how we you
know organize activism advocacy
spiritual principles and you know dare I
say the word religion it's such a it's
such a loaded word like I don't even
want to say that word because it
immediately alienates people and I have
my own weird you know kind of
relationship to all of that and part of
your book is is really a reprogramming
of how we think about that word and the
traditions and you do that by canvassing
you know you you do a deep dive into the
history of all these various you know uh
face
um what we can learn from them what has
gone by acknowledging what's gone
terribly awry with how Humanity has kind
of weaponized them in various ways but
how do we find our way back to the best
of what religion has to offer and why
should we reconsider
the importance of religion in this you
know kind of secular post-religious
[Music]
um
uh you know World in which we are over
indexing on intellectualism rationalism
the rise of atheism and our own kind of
bespoke you know uh you know versions of
spirituality you know as a side dish
over here
I don't I don't have any answers I mean
I took a stab at it by trying to invent
a new religion you did yeah I don't have
any answers I just I just proposed a new
religion in my book but please don't
call me I will say that I have
the Seven Pillars of a spiritual
Revolution do with that you do indeed
indeed you do
um and they are
to write a new mythology of humanity you
know the current mythology that we have
is like dog it's a doggy dog world and
one upsmanship and survival of the
fittest and don't tread on me and um
Live Free or Die and this this kind of
like uh uh you know the the strongest
survives we need to write a mythology
that remembers that we're a Cooperative
species that we've come together in
community that we have healed through
great traumas that we have lived for
most of our existence with great peace
with planet Earth right we need to
create a new mythology just like that I
use the Star Wars mythology as a as an
example of uh you know how to use a
Joseph Campbell you know hero's journey
where we we can do the same thing with
uh with our human I'm not going to read
through all of them but but just to
pause on that idea for a moment I mean
that's a big ask right especially in
America where it's all about rugged
individualism and staking your claim and
you're individualistic you know Pursuit
of Happiness and your rights and your
Liberty uh which I think overshadows
to you know hearken back to what we were
talking about earlier this this notion
of collective responsibility like
Liberty is only as powerful or as potent
as it is paired to the responsibility
that we shoulder for the collective
right and I think that that
responsibility piece has gotten lost in
this conversation and what you're saying
is we need to recapture that but it's
almost uh requires an undoing of the
very sensibility of the this this whole
kind of American
uh myth or or ideology
like uh rewriting that story is not a
small task it's not a small task
um
I don't know what's a what's a Way
Forward
um yeah I I don't I don't know how to
start I don't know yeah I don't know how
to start I mean I I think this mythology
of Don't Tread on Me Live Free or Die
every man for themselves pull yourself
up by your own bootstraps we came to
America for a very good reason we were
escaping puritanism although many of our
forefathers were Puritans who wanted to
be more Puritan right you know it wasn't
hardcore enough but yeah more hardcore
but then there were a lot of people that
just wanted to be out of the auspices of
being told what to do in the kind of
draconian bureaucracies of Europe at the
time so you know we we wanted guns and
we wanted land and we wanted freedom and
freedom of free speech and expression
and you know a lot of those things are
are are great I think
but again we just need more storytellers
to be telling the stories because you
think about Freedom have you ever been
to a country where there's no traffic
laws
yeah they just it's just a free-for-all
cars are just parked on sidewalks and
every man for themselves I remember
driving in Morocco was the first time
that was immediately the place that I
thought of yeah anyway the first time I
saw human brains splashed on to a street
because everyone just goes as fast as
they want through barreling down the
wrong side of the road the stop lights
are optional and and it doesn't work
it doesn't work it does not get you
there faster
Freedom total freedom and Morocco so in
in the United States and in countries
that have traffic laws we're like oh
we've got these traffic laws I don't
want to drive I Can't Drive 55 I don't
want to wear my seat belt you know but
these are all for a very good reason and
it actually works and it gets you there
faster and you're really grateful for
our traffic laws because it works so
I know that's just a lame dumb little
example but it's an example of uh you
know
reinvesting reinvestigating the word
freedom and what that really means
because freedom in the context of system
and cooperation is a really powerful
force but Freedom just on its own
without any kind of limits and without
any kind of morality for lack of a
better word is uh is extremely dangerous
yeah I mean it's a bottom-up thing is it
not like in order to uh you know kind of
shock people out of their own personal
agenda and you know self-seeking
and to contemplate the the well-being of
the greater whole
that requires a spiritual Revolution
right like you have it it's an elevation
of consciousness in order so here's my
challenge to you rich the next one here
is to Foster joy and squash cynicism
we've been talking a lot about that the
pessimism and cynicism that you feel
around this and I completely understand
and this is part of my Character defects
is to be cynical and pessimistic that I
I tend very easily in that direction
it's hard for me to be hopeful
um it's a practice but one of the super
powers of this kind of like
uh these Seven Pillars for a spiritual
Revolution is to Foster joy and squash
cynicism uh whenever that arises in our
chest we just have to know it's not
serving us I tell the story in here
about I worked with a great theater
teacher and director Andre Gregory who's
the star of focal point of the amazing
classic film My Dinner with Andre if
people haven't seen it it's absolutely
it's it's an entire two-hour movie of a
conversation with two people at a dinner
table and I got to work with him for
several weeks or several months and uh
uh
fascinating human being who's traveled
the world and done theater in every
culture of the world and is it just
beyond fascinating anyways he had a
meeting with me as he did with his
students and we had tea and then as we
were leaving he's like so what how do
you feel rain how are you these days I'm
like well I can't help but getting
cynical I'm kind of pessimistic how is
things going to work out and the world
is so dark and [__] up this was the
90s mind you when things were actually
pretty good and um yeah
he grabbed my arm hard
grabbed it he was a little old man then
he's still alive and he's like 98. he
grabbed my arm he looked into my eyes
he's like don't do it
don't do it don't give in to cynicism
don't be pessimistic if you do that they
win that's how they want you if you're
pessimistic if you're cynical they win
because you aren't going to do anything
to change the world it's you're going to
get shut down don't do it I mean he was
and he was just like held my gaze and
held my arm I was like 25 I was like and
then he let go and then I walked out
into the world and I saw things in an
entirely new way I won't say that I was
transformed and all of a sudden I was
arrived or anything like that but I'll
never forget that interaction and I
think that for all of the listeners for
you and the rich role Posse
um
it is so important to to Foster joy and
hope and everything that we do because
the other side the side of Darkness the
Empire you know yeah the the the the the
the Voldemort that forces that are out
there on they want us cynical they want
us pessimistic and they want us and
resultingly not doing anything so how do
we especially engender that and Inspire
that in the younger generation how do we
do that with teens how do we do that
with college kids and people in their
20s that are lost and dealing with this
rampant Mental Health crisis that's
killing Millions how do we Foster and
engender hope in that generation
whatever we can do that's our most
important task in front of us
um
that's beautiful yeah you know like you
my my default setting or my disposition
is you know as a as a tried and true gen
xer is to be cynical and it's it's work
it's a practice to keep that at Bay and
to try to find a way to hold on to Hope
or to you know cultivate
to cultivate that now as you were
sharing that beautiful story I was
thinking about
um Jane Goodall's the book of Hope have
you read this book no yes so it's a book
co-written by my friend uh Doug Abrams
and it's all about that like how do you
maintain hope in the face of dire
circumstances or you know all the all
the pressures of society that are kind
of marshalling you to you know believe
otherwise and he also wrote a book with
the Dalai Lama called The Book Of Joy
yeah and Desmond Tutu yeah yeah so oh
okay yeah same guy
um which are yeah those two books
together kind of speak to exactly what
you're saying yeah which is great
um I want to talk a little bit about uh
this idea of of of the Divine like what
is
sacred right like how do we think about
what is sacred in our world and and what
is not which is something you talk about
in the book what is Holy anymore like
what is deserving of reverence in the
modern world like how do we think about
what is and what is not sacred and how
has that changed or evolved over time
yeah I um
went with my family a few years back on
what is a Baha'i pilgrimage to
um
the North of Israel in the Haifa Israel
area
where the founder of the by faith is
buried which is the most kind of sacred
spot to Baha'is
and there are a number of other you know
shrines there that's where the Baha'i
administrative Center is and so it has a
lot of like power and and uh and Beauty
beautiful gardens and architecture you
can Google it and it was really profound
because we went on this journey with
people from like the Philippines and
Romania and Italy and in Finland and
like all over the world and a very
diverse group of people that were
Baha'is that came in to you know take
this nine-day journey of prayer and
meditation and to be devout you think
about that word devout which also is
connected to devotions devoted
um and it really when I got back home I
saw things in a very different way
because I was like
wow there's just nothing sacred around
me it was so weird to have nine days
when things were sacred and you would
you would pray and you would meditate
and you would Ponder things and you
would and you did it as a group and
uh it was really a beautiful experience
and then in contemporary Los Angeles it
feels like nothing is sacred I mean I
suppose if you do a dawn hike and you're
on you know and you're in the Santa
Monica Mountains and you see the sunrise
or something like that certainly that
has a sacredness and a connection to
Nature uh is is where sacred is but I I
used that story to kind of pose the
question about what is sacred in the
modern world and I reference the uh
great medieval Japanese uh poet Basho
who wrote Haiku and is considered like
the greatest Haiku poet of all time and
what he would do as part of just his
tradition is it's part travelogue it's
part spiritual journey and it's part uh
uh meditative journey and the connection
to Nature and it's a part of an artistic
journey is he would walk from town to
town and he would go to temples and
beautiful places and he would meditate
and pray where he was and then he would
write a poem about that place and he
would leave it at the local temple right
every day right every single day so it
was like this and you can track you can
go on his journey and he wrote this book
called uh sometimes it's called narrow
path to the interior
narrow path to the north
it has different kind of translations
and meanings and I thought about how
special that was that here's this person
combining
art right haiku
prayer and meditation a spiritual path
and kind of a cultural travelogue at the
same time visiting historical places and
highlighting the the sacredness of this
path and the way that he walked this
path so I just kind of issued a
challenge to the reader and and to
myself really like how do we find what's
sacred in our lives does it need to be
some special place where someone's
buried can we find I reference you know
Lambeau stadium and sure to the people
of Green Bay how sacred that stadium is
because the of the mighty Green Bay
Packers and that such a legendary
history so
yeah I'm just wondering if that
resonated for you or how you find the
sacred in your life yeah I mean I think
that that uh the idea of what is and
what is not sacred is really about our
relationship to things right the idea
that this Japanese poet could write
beautiful Haiku as he's traversing the
landscape he is you know creating art
out of mundanity right and in that there
is something sacred so you can create a
relationship of sacredness with whatever
is providing you with meaning or just
the just the effort of trying to be
present with something I think creates a
sacred relationship that's a really good
point it's not like you go to these far
away places and you also talk about
you know going to Israel and like you
know these historic The Wailing Wall and
all this sort of stuff like these these
uh you know artifices that are just you
know loaded with historic meaning that
are you know obviously uh agreed upon
sacred sites but I think that there's a
broader conversation to be had about
finding the sacred in our everyday lives
like how can we mine meaning and and and
be elevated by our own environments
right and that's just a decision that
you make and a decision to kind of
invest whatever experience you're having
with a with a more kind of uh
I don't know elevated conscious
awareness of of how it could be uh
awe-inspiring or wonder inducing rather
than just
mundane or normal or I mean can it be
can can you drive down the one-on-one
freeway in Los Angeles and and figure
out a way to you know find something
sacred about that I don't know maybe
well I was just thinking as you were
saying that what would it be like if we
wrote a haiku about every place that we
visited every single day yeah even in
the mundanity of our life even just
going to Trader Joe's and picking up
some Naval changes
the Rich Roll podcast
elevated
conversations now see I can't you can't
we can put a cpt4 onto it yeah we and
have it write out some good I'm doing it
doing it for us but but even that brings
a kind of an elevated Consciousness and
I think when you read the work of
Eckhart Tolle when you read the work of
tiknot Han who talks about being present
while you're washing the dishes how
that's the hardest task like part of it
is presence like to really be where you
are is it not
would say if you're completely present
with what you're doing there is nothing
that isn't sacred right like that uh you
know that capacity to be 100 in the
moment that you're in is there you know
it speaks to this idea of Oneness and
unity right like
human beings are
organisms that are always trying to
identify patterns and in that pattern
making kind of proclivity we tend to
other right like we're this they're that
this makes sense this doesn't I fit over
here those people are over there and it
it it belies the truth the greater truth
which is the Oneness of everything which
you speak so eloquently about in the
book
um and you know presence is a way of
transcending or overriding that that
default to kind of identify patterns
that are mechanisms of separation
hand in hand with that very well said is
what we can learn from indigenous
peoples and looking back into our
history because
if you look back far enough all of us
were at one point in time indigenous you
know my people were indigenous to the to
Norway and to the British Isles back in
the day but
when I think about Basho I think too
about art
nature because Haiku is always about
nature art nature spirituality religion
you know it comes from the Buddhist and
Shinto tradition
art nature and spirituality all converge
and there's no separation between them
so to strive for the sacred I would say
that
art Beauty nature and the spiritual are
all in are all unified and are working
together
um as the many Native American
traditions point us too so how do we do
that in the western Society
um
I don't know
you're supposed to have the answers I
don't have the answers I have the
questions yeah
well speaking of of
indigenous Traditions one thing you do
talk about in the book is is you know
how how we as modern individuals in
Western Society are always trying to
look for shortcuts to these answers and
one of those shortcuts is is you know
exploring traditions of the indigenous
in the form of plant medicine right and
the sort of pitfalls and also advances
that that you know these experiences
that people are having like I have a lot
of opinions about this but you're you're
pretty clear in how you feel about all
of this so explain kind of your
perspective here's my unpopular opinion
okay
it's an unpopular opinion that I share
so go ahead you're you're an unpopular
opinion oh that's good I didn't know
that you shared that um
I talk about quote unquote plant
medicine which by the way why isn't
heroin or cocaine a plant medicine yes
I've asked myself this question why is
it only like what we want is a plant
like we apply like also this idea that
it's the work
yeah do the work when you're you know
you're doing your taxes and doing the
work when you're do the work when you're
taking your family to the mall to get
some shoes
um yeah I feel very strongly because I
remember because I'm old enough to
remember people in the 70s who were
talking about LSD and what a revolution
that was in the early 60s and mid 60s
with Timothy Leary and drop in drop out
Etc and everyone doing acid and that
acid was the Gateway towards
self-realization and you know I met and
I haven't a couple uncles that fried
themselves in that way and met people
whose brains were just fried from doing
acid and they you could look in their
eyes and you saw rainbows in their eyes
but you'd also fry a lot of neurons
along the way and then I remember being
in college in the 80s and early 90s and
people like going to the going to do
peyote and going to do mushrooms in the
mountains and having these kind of like
experiences that are outside of the
daily where they're looking for this
Enlightenment and now with Ayahuasca I
feel like it's the same kind of thing
like oh my Sean the shaman went to the
Best Western in Tempe Arizona and I met
him there I used to go like to Panama
and Colombia and actual Amazon and now
like they're coming together like yeah
like down by LAX yeah but I know people
that have gone to literally just gone to
uh a conference room in a hotel to do
their Ayahuasca and I just feel like
it's a very American thing it's like I
wanna I wanna have this peak experience
I'm gonna pay you know 875 dollars to
fly the shaman up to Costa Rica or to
this Resort in Mexico and have this
experience it's going to change my mind
it's going to change how I see things
and
you know and but I'm gonna do it every
year or two and the rest of the year
[__] it I'm just gonna like I'm gonna be
an [__] just kind of try and make a
lot of money I'm gonna use my dating
apps yeah
You You Porn and and just you know uh
you know collect comic books and you
know go to the movies or whatever it is
that we do in our lives and it's a very
American kind of thing I think it's a
cop-out and I think it it we were
talking about a show we were talking
about wakan Tonka we're talking about
Eckhart Tolle like this this is hard
work you know spiritual transformation
is hard daily work now I can hear a lot
of people saying well I'm gonna do the
daily work but I just this will help me
see things in a different way and I know
people that have had a very powerful
effect and by the way I don't want to
take away from the efficacy of these
drugs to help people who are suffering
from severe extreme depression and from
severe extreme drug addiction that there
has been some proof that they have
worked on those things with you know a
professional you know and with a very
specific system in mind toward healing
that's not what I'm talking about I'm
talking about that recreational
touristic idea of I want to go get
Enlightenment in Costa Rica at a resort
and I can I've only got till Friday 3
P.M till Monday 10 a.m in order to do it
right because I got to get back for the
board meeting yeah yeah so I agree with
you 100 certainly there are efficacious
cases I know per people personally who I
think their lives have been benefited
from having these experiences and the
science that's coming out around uh you
know the use cases with respect to
depression PTSD and addiction as you
mentioned I think are are promising and
interesting I just think that the idea
that that
um we can have a casual relationship
with these very powerful substances and
that uh the main streaming of it such
that you know we're sort of lured into
this idea that that this should be part
of our like daily Wellness routine is is
irresponsible and I do think that tour
First Sensibility is problematic and it
is you know kind of so
um
uh you know emblematic of like America
in American sensibility like as somebody
who like went to rehab and I know people
I have a I know a guy who you know was
on ketamine and jumped off his roof like
these are not benign substances these
are very powerful substances that need
to be you know
um administered in controlled
environments in the best case scenario
uh and I think we just need to slow down
a little bit and like you know what you
know you don't need it to have a
transformation of spiritual experience
right and and it's really about like
to the extent that they can open up a
portal and allow you to step outside of
your ego and and see things maybe more
broadly I'm I'm cool with that like
great but that is only as valuable as
the follow-up work and the path that
you're going to pursue to kind of more
deeply invest in in what that means for
you right yeah and you you don't need to
do those things in order to have those
experiences and fast tracking your
Spiritual Development or growth is is
really not like what it's about
I met a young guy and he talked about
his Ayahuasca trip and how he saw
Oneness in all things and how all things
were connected and unified and it
actually gave him a belief in God and it
was really transformative and I was like
oh that's great what do you do and what
do you do what do you do what's your
life it's like well I buy sell and trade
uh sneakers and Air Jordans so I you
know I'll buy a sneaker for three
hundred dollars and I'll sell it to some
teenager in Ohio for five hundred
dollars and it's like
okay
all right now nothing against a little
Commerce I do I do some dumb commercials
sometimes to make some money but uh that
just seems antithetical to the spirit of
you know real profound Soul
transformation how judgmental of you
yeah there's my Character defects all
right I know
um yeah It's Tricky but I just you know
I guess my My overall kind of Vibe on
that is like slow down think twice
these are it's not a binary thing it's
not bad or good it's what is your
relationship to this what are you trying
to get out of it and what is the plan of
you know after these experiences what
are you going to do with it like I yeah
I have a friend who
I think he does it like every weekend
yeah you know and then he's like I'm
doing the work and I'm like dude like
are you not enlightened yet like what
are you doing like this is an escape on
some level like how are you
incorporating this into your life I did
the work 15 years every day with alcohol
I was doing the work yeah
it didn't it didn't it didn't it didn't
it didn't work such a bummer it didn't I
wish it did it didn't soothe me it
didn't allow me to escape my pain and my
anxiety and it didn't didn't quell the
fear and so what I am what is the what
is the daily practice now look like for
you so uh I would say about four or five
days a week uh I am able to uh wake up
in the morning and read a holy writing
from my faith tradition which reminds me
about my spiritual Essence and my
spiritual nature that I am a spiritual
being having a human experience as a
pair tahart Des Chardon says then I do
um a meditation uh for a very simple one
15 or 20 minutes nothing fancy and
um and then I exercise even lightly jog
up and down my driveway which is kind of
a hill and lightly lift some weights and
stuff to help reduce my anxiety and then
I do a cold immersion uh even for just
three and a half you got the cold plunge
I have a cold plunge although most of
the year in La my pool does the trick
just live right and I and I fool myself
it's like oh it's 59 degrees that's cold
enough yeah I don't need to get in does
it need to be 39. I don't need to get in
the 45 degree tub but that has really
helped with my mental health with my
anxiety
um and in the Baha'i tradition we pray
uh between noon and sunset a very simple
prayer that connects us to our creator
um and then I um read another uh quote a
spiritual quote in the in the evening
um you know there's usually you know in
12-step programs where you know we're
making calls and reaching out and like
connecting with people in the program
which is part of its beauty and the
community that it creates so I'm
I'm rolling uh Rich rolling phone calls
as well and kind of living in
consultation with my with my brothers
and support group so
um and then I do therapy I'm very
serious about therapy and part of what
my therapist does is uh hypnosis so I do
at least twice a month I'm doing
hypnotherapy which I think is uh uh
really powerful yeah kind of Forgotten
kind of therapy it was like big in the
70s or whatever and you hear about it if
not at all hypnosis like
you're a chick pretend you're a chicken
or something like that it's just getting
in touch with that enormous reservoir of
the unconscious sure
um and I think you mentioned last time
you do like a men's group you still do
that yeah yeah yeah I do a men's group
Retreat every uh three or four months we
get together a you know an Airbnb or
someone's house and we do intensive you
know step study and sharing and
um and bonding activities and and stuff
like that to because intimacy among
grown men as you know is really
difficult and it's something that's
really lacking in our culture uh yeah
the only way men can bond is
over Sports really and and you know
playing sports and and watching sports
and and stuff like that so you know
sharing with other middle-aged men and
being vulnerable and
um asking for feedback help and you know
consultation is is a powerful force yeah
I think modeling that is is super
important especially when it comes to
kind of untangling that knot like when
we think about
what's required to elevate Consciousness
in order to more efficaciously like
solve these problems in a healthy way
like the big problems that we have a lot
of it you know kind of tracks back to
um
you know masculine models of of you know
unhealth like our inability to kind of
communicate uh or or be honest about our
emotions or you know check our ego and
all these sorts of things that like kind
of you know have this undercurrent of
like driving culture in the wrong
direction and you know pushing us
towards that you know existential cliff
I remember when I first got into therapy
um in the early 2000s in LA and someone
recommended a therapist and he ended up
being really great and they
and he would say like so rain what's
going on and I would kind of summarize
what I did that week and then like so
how are you feeling and I was just like
I had literally had no vocabulary to
talk about what was going on inside I it
wasn't that
I was I was flummoxed I literally didn't
have language and he had this kind of
poster of this emotion wheel and it was
like is it this and I'd be like I'd be
like well I'm I'm pretty frustrated with
my career let's say like so I would do a
superficial thing and he'd be like
frustrated okay and you pull out this
like emotion color wheel and it was like
frustrated you know and it had different
variations of it like irked uh irate
um overwhelmed it's like do any of those
like actually overwhelmed yeah
overwhelmed that's what I'm feeling
overwhelmed oh okay how does that make
you feel and then I'd have another
emotion and like I had to learn a
language because no one had taught or
modeled it for me the language of how to
have feelings and how to communicate
those feelings I was just so locked up
and constipated yeah
um and and the idea that to do that
somehow threatens
uh your masculinity right like it's a
it's a threat to like this identity uh
you know of what it means to be a man
and
um I think it's so important to do that
and and I think your guy Justin baldoni
yeah like he's like at the Leading Edge
of like trying to educate people about
this in in a really interesting way he's
caught a lot of flack for that he's
really yeah he's gotten this great uh
book and podcast called man enough where
he really challenges his own ideas about
his masculinity and obviously he's like
a model handsome guy
but he talks about how like you know if
he was doing a show and he had to take
his shirt off like for weeks in advance
he would just feel less I mean he's got
washboard right I mean they're insane
and he just feel less than and judged
and overwhelmed and like and his body
and he wasn't enough and
um but they really take apart
masculinity in some interesting ways on
that podcast and in his book and well
he's caught a lot of flack from it I
mean he gets lambasted online what is
the what is the negative feedback
I guess it's the um Andrew Tate
contingent of like you're a cuck and a
[__] to kind of even question what
being a man really is and you're you're
emasculated and you're you're [__]
whipped and uh there is you know there's
a there's a population that views any
challenges to masculinity as you know
some kind of very threatening affront
and uh and a dangerous Direction
for Humanity to go which is men having
feelings being vulnerable expressing
their feelings asking for their needs to
be met yeah
um
that's problematic that is a concern you
know yeah uh I guess the idea of uh
you're better off just getting in your
Lambo and and smoking your cigar and and
your weed yeah exactly yeah you know I
don't know
um
I don't know what to think about that uh
uh that's upsetting because I I see what
Justin's doing and I think it's so cool
yeah and the fact that there's organized
pushback to that
um is disconcerting yeah I suppose
um so we got to wrap this up but
you know maybe you know we can kind of
close this with with just some thoughts
around
why you think it's worthwhile and
meaningful for somebody to cultivate
um a spiritual connection or to to
Really grapple with you know these ideas
that that kind of transcend the the you
know Material World in which you know
kind of predominates our our daily
experience for somebody who's listening
to this or watching it
for whom maybe they have a negative uh
uh reaction to religion because of the
way they were brought up or they have an
allergy to anything spiritual
um you know bake the case for why this
is worthwhile for somebody to kind of
mine or explore gladly thank you great
question
so the first thing I will say is
the reason why spirituality is important
is because it is reality
so what is reality I'm fully in
agreement with tehar de Chardon who said
we are not human beings having a
spiritual experience we Are Spiritual
Beings having a human experience I fully
know uh goes beyond belief I fully know
that I am a soul and that I am
inhabiting or attached to or in
connection with a bodily form for
who knows how long 60 70 90 years I'm
not sure how long it'll last and that is
my reality and the who I am and what I
am is not my body it's not even my
personality it's not even like the
background that I
you know it's not the trauma I suffered
it's not what I've been through that
there is a little spark of the Divine
inside of me or that is part of me that
is reflecting the Majesty of the Divine
of God the divine presence the creative
Force just like a sunflower turns to the
Sun and follows the sun throughout the
course of the day that is a reality so
for me to deny my reality is is not
beneficial to anyone and at least at
least if not myself so now if you're a
hardcore atheist and you're like that's
[__] prove it to me uh prove to me
this Divine spark of which you speak I
want to see it in a laboratory or in an
algorithm or on a computer screen well
that's not quite how it works because
every spiritual tradition will show you
that we live in a matrix that we live in
an illusion and when we wake up from
this Corporal form we're going to be in
some greater reality and this is this
this has come from the atheists this
idea that you know perhaps we're this
we're living in an avatar a similar the
simulacrum you know and uh we're living
in a fleshy Avatar and we're going to
wake up to some greater reality but
putting all that aside I would say for
to the atheist or agnostic that try it
and see if your life is better because
there is hard uh we talked about Dr Lisa
Miller and her work there's hard data
that shows around mental health and
well-being that having
um Serenity meaning purpose focus a
sense of service to other others a
losing of oneself to a Transcendent self
of the Divine the Transcendent the
abundance that's around us increases
greatly the quality of Our Lives when we
see ourselves in true humility with the
size and scope of the universe and
whatever infinite universes are Beyond
this year universe that it makes the
quality of your life better so cost
benefit analysis putting in a small
amount of time every day I'm talking
about
40 minutes in your day to some kind of
spiritual
um
opening uh and and or practice has
incredible benefits this has been found
time and time again it's found in the
12-step programs it's found in Buddhist
Meditation it's found in the most
ancient texts that Humanity has ever
proved uh created the The Vedas and
upanishads from you know 3000 years ago
this sense that we are a wave on the sea
of creation and the wave crests and the
wave Falls we're a part of something
much greater and much more beautiful
than ourselves and in living in that
state can greatly enrich your life how
is that I think uh you know despite the
fact that you are shunning the mantle of
Guru you might have just uh inherited
because I was like pretty well said and
uh very inspiring I have no interest in
being a guru I am however interested in
the cash the cash yeah cashing in on a
casual ship thought leader
yeah spiritual Pioneer maybe like
Retreats yeah that cost uh fourteen
hundred dollars or something like that I
think uh I think you're well I mean this
book is like basically the foundation of
a whole new thing for you dude man I'm
not gonna you know no I'm uh I'm gonna
I'm a lonely I'm but a lonely awkward
actor I'll be playing my next weirdo
character on television screens near you
it's funny uh what you just said I think
uh you know guys in the back clip that
that is an Instagram reel uh we didn't
even talk about the fact that the last
time you were on I mean we had some
texts about it but that
um monologue that you delivered around
like your 20s are for like [__]
around and Exploring Life and like
trying things and trying failing and
failing and all of that like went you
know crazy viral yeah millions of you
created like uh a really interesting
discussion and dialogue that was split
like oh a lot of people like amen
probably the older people right like oh
I wish I'd done that or whatever and
then um an interesting pushback of some
younger people like you don't understand
my life or that's convenient for you but
like you know this is my circumstance
and which is great like that's a
dialogue I would view it differently I
would view the younger people were like
thank you that put so much in Clarity
gave me so much Clarity some yes but
some like barriers up like hey like
scared of that message I think many
people viewed it as like oh that's just
an invitation to like [__] around and
not do anything but no it's try things
learn explore fail but don't worry about
it you don't even know who the hell you
are I know but it's like when you're
that age you can't hear that because
like you think like everything is so
um
you know uh time sensitive and precious
and you've got to get on it and all of
that I had uh
um you know Kevin Kelly is I had him in
here the other day found a founder of
Wired Magazine okay yeah like legendary
like futurist big thinker kind of guy
and he like dropped out of college after
a year and like lived in Asia for years
and like basically said everything that
you said In that clip and I was like
yeah that's what rain said and he's
coming back it's cool
I loved how viral that went and I love
that it's provoking a conversation and
that's what I hope to do with soul boom
Soul boom why we need a spiritual
Revolution is we are here to Market your
book this is my purpose ring oh come on
let's stop it but I but I do I do I do
have more questions than answers so it's
just it's an important conversation we
need to be digging into you know what
our spiritual tools can they benefit us
personally and can they benefit us
collectively let's talk about it sure
and I think it's important to point out
uh that that you have a a sense of
humility about this whole thing like we
didn't really talk about that but like
you're sort of self-deprecating
throughout this whole thing like hey I
don't have the answers but let's ask
these questions and like hey how
Preposterous is it of me to be writing
this book and and uh you know using like
kind of fun examples from pop culture to
illustrate like these deeper points that
you're making and
um it's a really it's it's it strikes a
balance between being super deep and and
provocative and asking a lot of the
reader while also being really fun and
easy to read like I I literally you are
Marketing in like a day you are
marketing my book it is I I loved it
it's great I'm excited for you I love
what you do on your podcast and uh the
conversations that you have are so
important um and the the scope of what
they are from veganism to Wellness to
exercise to uh to to Greater
Consciousness and you are
you are on the Star Trek path of uh
making Humanity a better place and uh
helping mature our species thank you for
that well I I appreciate that but I
think what we can conclude from this
conversation is that we should each be
each other's publicist yeah we should I
will say
um I love you buddy this book is great
I'm super excited for people to
experience it and uh I'm at your service
and there's always a chair for you here
I love it thank you love you too thanks
for having us thanks it's been a
wonderful discussion peace
all right cool